Guten Abend.
Hallo, guten Abend.
Elis ist mein Name. Ich bin der Dienstherbinderarzt auf diese Station.
Und werde mit Ihnen Aufnahmegespräch führen. Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Hauptsache, Sie sind ein Arzt. Herr Dr. Guten Abend. Schön, dass Sie da sind.
Ja, ich bin da für Sie.
Und wie heißen Sie denn?
Mein Name ist Friedrich Wodringer.
Könnten Sie bitte Ihre Vor- und Nachname langsam burschen?
Mein Vornamen ist Friedrich.
Fr. Ida Hemil.
Doran.
Richard Ida. Cesar Heinrich. Friedrich.
Kann sein.
Ja, genau. Nachname bitte.
Mein Nachname ist Wodringer.
Walter Otto.
Theodor Theodor, also ein Doppeltee.
Richard Ida.
Nordpol.
Gustav.
Emil Richard. Wodringer.
Und wie alt sind Sie?
Herr Wodringer.
Und wann genau sind Sie geboren?
Also, ich bin 72 Jahre alt.
72?
Okay. Und wann genau sind Sie geboren?
Ich bin geboren am 25. März.
1950.
Und wie groß sind Sie, Herr Wodringer?
Sie wollen aber Sachen lösen, Herr Editz.
Ich glaube, ich bin ein bisschen kleiner geworden.
Ich war mal 1 Meter 85.
Jetzt bin ich nur noch 1 Meter 81.
Ja, das kann sein. Ja, ich verstehe.
Und wie viel wiegen Sie, wenn Fragen da ab?
Also, bis vor einem Jahr habe ich noch 103 kg gewogen.
Und jetzt wiege ich nur noch 85 kg.
85 kg.
Und jetzt sind wir schon ungefähr 15 kg abgenommen, oder?
Ja, das stimmt. Ja, ja.
Das war gewollt oder ungewollt?
Nein, nicht ungewollt. Ja.
Also ich wollte schon abnehmen, aber nicht so viel.
Aber das ist von alleine so weggegangen.
Ja, verstehe.
Herr Wodringer.
Wie kann ich Ihnen helfen? Was gerne für Sie tun?
Herr Doktor, ich fühle mich schon seit ungefähr eine Woche schon
sehr müde, sehr schlapp.
Ich kann kaum aus dem Bett rauskommen.
Irgendwie fühle ich mich sehr kaputt.
Ja, das verstehe.
Haben Sie irgendwelche Ausschlösser für diese Beschwerden bemerkt?
Ich weiß es nicht. Das hat sich eigentlich nichts geändert.
Aber ich will nur noch schlafen.
Ich habe keinen Appetit.
Mein Blutdruck ist ganz, ganz niedrig.
Ich komme kaum aus dem Bett.
Was ist niedrig?
Mein Blutdruck.
Das ist niedrig.
Messen Sie sich regelmäßig Ihre Blutdruck, oder?
Ja, ich sehe Sie, hier ist meine Tabelle.
Normalerweise habe ich immer einen Blutdruck zwischen 120 und 130.
Und jetzt ist er immer so zwischen 80, 90 oder 100.
Das ist der erste Wert.
Ja, Herr Wotringer,
haben Sie noch irgendwelche Beschwerde,
aus der Möglichkeit, wie zum Beispiel Schmerzen,
Fieber, oder Schwindeln?
Schwindeln habe ich jetzt nur manchmal, nicht so oft,
aber Schmerzen, ja gut, ich habe immer schon chronische Rückenschmerzen.
Aber sonst etwas Neues, anderes habe ich jetzt nicht.
Ich bin sehr, sehr müde.
Meine Frau sagt, ich habe vor zwei Tagen fast 18 Stunden nur noch geschlafen.
Diese Rückenschmerzen sind neulich aufgetreten, oder?
Nein, nein, das habe ich immer, diese Rückenschmerzen.
Das ist nichts Neues.
Haben Sie irgendwelche Erklärung dafür für diese Rückenschmerzen?
Ja, Sie fragen mich Sachen, deswegen bin ich doch hier bei Ihnen.
Woher soll ich denn wissen, warum ich das habe?
Die Rückenschmerzen habe ich schon seit Jahren.
Das ist die Atrose, das weiß ich.
Und für nur, aber heute, und für jeden herrher,
ist der Herr Doktor noch da?
Ja, ja, ich bin da.
Es gab ein Verwindungproblem, oder?
Ja, so etwas.
Okay, Herr Wodringer.
Ist Ihnen übel auch?
Manchmal ja.
Was meinen Sie mit manchmal?
Jeden Tag manchmal oder ein paar Mal in einem Monat, oder so?
Nein, ich sage, es geht mir seit einer Woche.
Das ist jetzt meist morgens, habe ich auch eine Übelkeit, ja.
Ich habe schon gefragt, aber Sie haben noch nicht geantwortet.
Hatten Sie Februar?
Das habe ich nicht gemessen, aber...
Fühlen Sie sich feberig?
Nein, an sich nicht.
Ich fühle mich nur sehr geschwächt und müde.
Okay.
Seit einer Woche können Sie Ihre alltägliche Aufgaben erledigen?
Ich bin nur noch im Bett, ich schlafe die meiste Zeit.
Können Sie normal laufen oder müssen Sie Schlaufkrause machen?
Herr Doktor, Sie verstehen mich, glaube ich, nicht, oder?
Sie fragen immer die gleiche Frage.
Was soll das?
Ich bin hier, dass Sie mir helfen, und Sie fragen immer die gleiche Frage.
Verstehen Sie das nicht, Herr Doktor?
Sie sind doch der Arzt.
Ich habe eine Frage gegeben,
dass ich seit einer Woche im Bett lege,
und Sie fragen mich, ob ich laufen kann.
Was soll das?
Wenn Sie Ihre Sache nicht können, dann gehe ich woanders hin.
Ihr ist ein anderer Arzt da, bitte.
Das geht ja so nicht.
Meine Güte.
Herr Rotrinker, ich verstehe Ihre...
Sie sagen immer, ich verstehe,
aber ich glaube, Sie verstehen mich gar nicht, Herr Doktor.
Ja, Sie haben nicht...
Ich wollte nur sicher sein.
Ich glaube, ich muss Ihnen stellen.
Dadurch kann ich
bereits wichtige Rückschlüsse
auf Ihre Erkrankung ziehen.
Ich habe ein Problem,
deswegen bin ich hier bei Ihnen.
Ja, ja.
Ich möchte, dass Sie mir helfen, bitte.
Ich weiß nicht, warum ich gefragt bin.
Deswegen bin ich doch da.
Sie sind doch der Arzt.
Das mache ich gleich.
Und wir sind gleich doch, ja.
Okay.
Herr Rotrinker,
haben Sie irgendwelche Beschwerden
beim Maser lassen oder Stuhlgang?
Nein.
Haben Sie Nachtschweiß?
Meistmal.
Jetzt in den letzten 2-3 Tagen
habe ich 2-mal
so in der Nacht geschwitzt,
aber das war über noch ganz kurz.
Haben Sie Atemnot
oder solche Atemprobleme?
Nein.
Ich finde mich schon bedingt,
nur schwach,
sobald ich versuche,
aufzustehen und auf Toilette zu gehen.
Es fällt mir sehr schwer.
Ich bin kraftlos.
Aber Atemnot an sich habe ich nicht.
Nein.
Haben Sie irgendwelche
Herz-Rhythmusänderungen
gemerkt?
Nein.
Haben Sie irgendwelche
Farbeveränderungen auf Ihre Haut bemerkt?
Also,
mir persönlich ist da nichts aufgefallen.
Aber meine Frau
sagt,
dass ich so ein bisschen blass aussehe.
Diese
Blässlichkeit seit 1 Woche
oder war immer da?
Nein.
Seit den letzten 2 Tagen.
Okay.
Sie haben gesagt,
dass Sie
keine Probleme beim Stuhlgang haben.
Sind Sie sicher?
Ja, habe ich doch gesagt.
Keine
Farbeveränderung?
Nein.
Haben Sie irgendwelche
Vorerkrankungen?
Ja, ich habe sehr viele
Vorerkrankungen.
Zum Beispiel?
Ich hatte ein
Blasenkrebs
für einem
Herz-Rhythmus.
Vor einem
halben Jahr
hat man mir
die Blase, die Haarnblase entfernt.
Okay.
Seitdem habe ich
auch
davor schon viel
Gewicht verloren.
Ich habe
sehe Sie,
ich denke immer sehr langsam
jetzt auch, ich kann nicht so schnell reden.
Ich habe
einen Diabetes.
Ich benutze
seit vielen Jahren schon Insulin.
Was meinen Sie
mit vielen Jahren?
10, 20.
Was meinen Sie mit vielen Jahren?
Ja, schon seit 20 Jahren.
20? Okay.
Und
da fehlt mir jetzt in Zeit
1 Woche auf, dass meine Blutzuckerwerte
sehr hoch sind.
Ich hatte jetzt zum Beispiel letzte
Nacht einen Blutzuckerwert
von 385.
Vorgestern
sogar 430.
Das habe ich noch nie gehabt.
Trotzdem, aber haben Sie
kein Wasserlassenproblem, oder?
Doch,
das ist halt weniger geworden.
Ich merke jetzt keine Beschwerden, aber
ich merke,
der Urin riecht ein bisschen komisch.
Ja.
Und wie
geht das Urin aus?
Drück, klar.
Nein,
kann ich jetzt nicht sagen, aber es ist etwas
dunkler als sonst.
Und
mein Appetit ist weg.
Also an Vorerkrankungen, ich habe einen Blutdruck
normalerweise gehabt
und hatte einige Medikamente, aber
die habe ich jetzt nicht mehr genommen,
nachdem mein Blutdruck so abgefallen ist
und ich so müde geworden bin.
Ich habe die weggelassen.
Ich habe dann ansonsten noch
ein Herzinfarkt gehabt
vor
12 Jahren
und
ich habe dann noch
ein Stent
in meinem rechten Bein wegen
Blutungsstörungen.
Das ist so noch ein paar andere Sachen.
Noch ein paar andere Sachen,
die sind nicht wichtig, die Dinge, oder?
Ja, gut.
Ich hatte gesagt, ich habe so Rückenschmerzen.
Das war ein Bandscheim-Corefile.
Das war ein Arthrose.
Ja.
Und so weiter.
Herr Wottinger,
ich stehe.
Was glaubt ihr, Herr Doktor, was es ist?
Herr Wottinger,
gehen Sie regelmäßig
zu Kontrolle,
zu Vorsorge oder
zum Hausarzt?
Ja, das ist ein
sehr guter Hausarzt.
Er kontrolliert
alle
sechs bis acht Wochen mein Blutbild.
Ich schaue nach den Zuckerwerten.
Ich schaue nach anderen Werten,
nach meinen Nieren.
Auch eine Nieren-Schwäche,
eine Niereninsuffizienz habe ich auch.
Das habe ich vergessen zu sagen.
Das ist ein
sehr guter Hausarzt.
Ich habe auch die
Verkaufung von
der Stabile.
Das habe ich vergessen zu sagen.
Das ist ein
sehr guter Hausarzt.
Er meinte,
die letzte Kontrolle war vor
ca. drei Wochen,
da war alles stabil.
Alles in Ordnung, so wie bisher auch.
Hatten Sie
irgendwelche
infektiöse
Erkrankungen
vor ein paar Wochen?
Das war ein sehr guter Hausarzt.
Was haben Sie denn
gemacht?
Erkältung oder Mandelnentschuldung?
Erkältung hatte ich nicht.
Aber ich bin auch beim Urologen.
Das habe ich vergessen.
Ich habe auch ein
Prostata-Creebs gehabt.
Vor
acht Jahren ungefähr.
Ich habe immer wieder
nach meiner Prostata-Operation
Hahnwex-Infekte.
Aber
das wollte ich jetzt erzählen.
Siegensieh, ich bin jetzt völlig durcheinander.
Ich bin so vergesst nicht geworden,
Herr Doktor.
Das wird auch immer schlimmer.
Ja, verstehe.
Herr Wotkinger,
ich würde
gerne über Ihre Beschwerden
eine kurze Zusammenfassung.
Seit einer Woche
leiden Sie unter
Möglichkeit
Sie können ihre zägliche Aufgaben nicht machen.
Sie müssen meistens im Bettruhe bleiben.
Ja.
Sie haben diese Krankungen, Glasengrebs, Diabetes und Bluthochdruck.
Vor zwölf Jahren haben Sie unter Herzinfarkt gelitten.
Vor acht Jahren hat eine Post-Tata-Kirps festgestellt.
Wo denn Sie behandelt?
Ja.
Das ist korrekt.
Sie haben kein Feber und kein Problem beim Stuhlgang.
Aber beim Wasserlassen haben Sie manchmal Schwierigkeiten.
Sie haben schon dunkle Farbeveränderungen im Urin gemerkt.
Ja.
Seit ein paar Tagen, seit drei bis vier Tagen,
haben Sie Nachtschweiz und leiden Sie unter Appetitlosigkeit.
Ja.
Nehmen Sie irgendwelche Medikamente regelmäßig außer in Julien?
Ja, ich nehme Bluthoch-Tabletten.
Ja, wissen Sie die Namen?
Das war Amnudipine.
Das habe ich jetzt pausiert.
Das nehme ich jetzt eine Woche nicht mehr, weil der Bluthoch so niedrig ist.
Wie viele Medikamente nehmen Sie?
Das sind fünf Medikamente.
Morgens, oder?
Ja.
Und noch?
Dann habe ich Metaprolol 50.
Dann nehme ich zwei Stück.
Eine morgens, eine Abend.
Ich habe Thorazemitz 10 mg.
Eine morgens.
Ich habe Xarelto 20 mg.
Die Gergen Prostator, oder?
Xarelto.
Nein, das ist Blutverdünnung.
Blutverdünnung, okay.
Dann nehme ich eine am Tag.
Und wie gesagt, die Insulin.
Dann nehme ich Aktrapit.
Also ein kurzwerksames Insulin, dreimal am Tag.
Immer zum Essen.
Und dann so ein langwerksames Insulin.
Das Lantus.
Amstern.
Wie viel Einheit spritzen Sie?
Lantus.
Lantus habe ich 36 Einheiten.
Ich habe mich nicht getraut, etwas mehr zu spritzen.
Obwohl der Zucker bei fast 400 war, wird auch nicht besser.
Ich weiß nicht, was ich machen soll.
Ja, jetzt habe ich wieder vergessen.
Was haben Sie vergessen?
Ich wollte Ihnen die Medikamente noch sagen, aber habe ich jetzt vergessen.
Wogegen nehmen Sie diese Medikamente?
Ändern Sie sich daran?
Gleich fällt mir noch ein, aber im Moment habe ich vergessen.
Okay, das kann ich auch denken.
Wo sind Sie schon mal operiert, außer Blasenkrebs und Postdatafelbs?
Ja, ich hatte gesagt, ich habe einen Herzinfarkt gehabt.
Da habe ich zwei Stands bekommen.
Ja.
Und ich habe, stimmt, sehen Sie, einen Defi.
Er hat mir nach dem Herzinfarkt gesetzt.
Das habe ich vergessen zu sagen.
Ich habe gesagt, ich habe einen Stand im rechten Bein.
Im rechten Bein auch?
Ihren Herz?
Ich habe hier am Herzen, Stands und am Bein.
Im Herz, zwei Stands und im Bein auch einen Stand.
Ein Stand, ja.
Wo trinken Sie?
Nein.
Sind Sie schon immer nicht raucher?
Ich habe früher mal gerauft, aber nur kurz für ein paar Jahre.
Und trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, schon ab und zu mal Gläschen Wein.
An Abend trinke ich noch.
Reagieren Sie auf Stoff oder Medikamente allergisch?
Sind meine, ob ich allergien gegen Medikamente habe.
Da gibt es einen Antibiotikum, habe ich vergessen.
Das ist so etwas wie Penicillin.
Dagegen bin ich allergisch.
Wie äußert sich die Allergie?
Ich habe einen Ausschlag bekommen am ganzen Körper.
Das war ganz schlimm.
Dann hieß es, ich soll das Medikament nicht mehr nehmen.
Aber ich habe den Namen vergessen.
Muss ich meine Frau mal fragen.
Sind Sie vorstandgeimpft?
Ach, das weiß ich nicht.
Das überwacht meinen Hausarzt.
Die Impfungen sind alle komplett.
Ich gebe mal davon aus.
Was haben Sie regelmäßig gegen Influencer?
Was ist Influencer?
Grippe.
Meine Grippe-Impfung.
Ja, die lasse ich mir jedes Jahr machen.
Ich wollte dieses Jahr auch.
Aber ich bin jetzt etwas krank geworden.
Was glauben Sie, Herr Doktor, was ich habe?
Ich rede jetzt schon so lange.
Ich habe eine Vermutung.
Es kann von Ihren Nähren betroffen werden.
Aber soll ich Sie ausführlich und körperlich untersuchen?
Dann machen Sie das doch bitte.
Wie bitte?
Wir sind gleich später durchführen.
Ich habe noch ein paar Fragen.
Noch mehr Fragen?
Ja, ich verstehe.
Ich bin so geschwächt, ich kann kaum reden.
Sie fragen mich und fragen mich und fragen mich.
Können wir weitermachen, Herr Bodringer?
Ich weiß nicht, ob wir weitermachen.
Ich bin so müde und geschwächt.
Ich habe Ihre Fragen, Herr Doktor.
Aber diese Fragen nur für Sie.
Für Ehre nutzen.
Ich hoffe doch, Herr Doktor.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Sie haben schon gesagt.
Ja, ich bin verheiratet.
Was hat das mit dieser Erkrankung zu tun?
Ich habe ein Problem, um zu fragen, wie es meine Frau geht.
Sie sind aber ein komischer Arzt.
Das ist eine Routinevorlage.
Können wir das später erklären, wenn es mir besser geht?
Ja, natürlich.
Wir können nachher bei der Untersuchung Informationen ausführen.
Aber das ist fast fertig.
Ja, ich hoffe doch, bitte.
Und war Ihre Eltern krank?
Ich vermute, dass Ihre Eltern nicht mehr leben, oder?
Genau, meine Eltern sind beide schon gestorben.
Erinnern Sie sich daran, woran sie gestorben sind?
Ach, Doktor, Sie stellen Fragen.
Ich weiß nicht mal, was ich heute gegessen habe.
Sie fragen mich, woran sie gestorben sind.
Manchmal kann es relevant sein, mit Ihren Beschwerden.
Das weiß ich nicht mehr. Tut mir leid.
Okay.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, ich habe einen Sohn.
Ist er gesund?
Glücklicherweise geht ihm gut.
Er hat keine Erkrankungen.
Was hatten Sie als beruflich gemacht?
Ich war Polizist.
Ich habe bei der Polizei gearbeitet.
Ja, deswegen können Sie mich genau verstehen.
Manchmal müssen wir auch manche Formulas ausfüllen.
Ach, Doktor, jetzt kommen Sie nicht mit englischem Bürokratie.
Ich bin hier sehr krank.
Sie wollen ja auch englischem Bürokratie wissen.
Ich glaube, es ist jetzt genug, Herr Doktor.
Wir sind jetzt fertig.
Möchten Sie etwas ergänzen oder hinzufügen?
Nein, ich möchte wissen, was ich habe.
Ich verstehe das nicht und warum ich krank bin.
Ja, wie ich gesagt habe, es kann über Ihre Nähren relevant sein.
Oder wegen Ihrer Blasen oder Postart.
Deswegen bin ich da.
Sie müssen mich untersuchen.
Sie dürfen einen Platz nehmen und bin ich gleich bei Ihnen.
Vielen Dank.
Das hat sehr lange gedauert.
Jetzt gibt es ein paar Untersuchungsergebnisse.
Im Labor.
Im Lutbild, Hemoglobin 7,5.
Leukozytten 13.000.
Trombozytten 120.000.
Kreatinäen 1,8.
GFR 23.
Glutzucker.
GFR, noch mal bitte.
23.
Glutzucker.
435.
CAP 186.
Urin, Glutik, Mikrochematurin.
Nitrit positiv.
Leukozytten, Protein und Zucker.
Potasium.
Im Urin.
Im Blut.
Potasium ist Kalium, glaube ich.
Kalium 5,6.
GOT, GPT.
Leicht erhöht.
Bilorubin 1,2.
Ja, das reicht erst mal.
Okay.
Bitte so schnell wie möglich in Tensi Station.
Blutdruck 80 zu 60.
Puls 64.
Unregelmäßig.
Das sind die Befunde.
Jetzt können Sie an den Oberarzt Ihre Verdachtsdiagnose mitteilen.
Jetzt, Dr. Al-Fazir, mal die Themen.
Aber, weil er ein Kind ist, hat er etwas von der Seite.
Aber, gut.
8 Minuten, Mama.
Guten Abend, Herr Oberarzt.
Hallo.
Guten Abend, Herr Dr.
Wie geht es Ihnen?
Danke und wohin?
Danke schön.
Was ist los?
Ich habe eine neue Patientin.
Haben Sie kurz Zeit für mich?
Dann erzählen Sie mal, was haben Sie für einen Patienten aufgenommen?
Ich bin sehr gespannt.
Vielen Dank, Herr Oberarzt.
Ein 72-jähriger Patient.
Friedrich Rodringer.
Heute bei uns wegen seit einer Woche
allmählich aufgetretenen Bestände
und vertierenden Müdigkeit vorgestellt.
Der Patient hat keine Auslöser dafür bemerkt
und teilt mit auch an Nausea und Schwindigkeit.
Schwindel.
Ja, genau.
Ihre Frau hat auch Bläßigkeit bemerkt,
seit einer Woche.
Und ich habe wirklich viele Erkrankungen.
Ich würde von denen erwähnen.
Ich habe Blasenkrebs vor einem Jahr.
Ich habe eine andere Frau,
die eine Frau hat,
eine Blasenkrebs vor einem halben Jahr behandelt.
Was ist gemacht worden?
Wie ist der an der Blase behandelt worden?
Ich habe nicht gefragt, aber ich kann nachher wieder fragen.
Ist er operiert worden?
Oder hat man ausgeschält oder die Blase entfernt?
Die Blase ist entfernt worden.
Prostatakatsinum hatte er vor acht Jahren.
Er wurde wegen Katsinum operiert.
Er hat auch Atterila Hypertoni.
Bis jetzt.
Er nahm am Lodipin.
Aber seit einer Woche waren Blutdokvertein niedergeht.
Er hat abgesetzt.
Er hat Medikamente abgesetzt.
Er hat es gut gemacht.
Vor zwölf Jahren hatte er Neocardinfat.
Deswegen hat er eine Defibrillation eingesetzt.
Er hat zwei Stands eingesetzt.
Er hat zwei Stands und einen Defibrillator.
Er hat einen TVT eingesetzt.
Er hat einen PAVK eingesetzt.
Er hat einen Stands eingesetzt.
Jetzt muss ich nachfragen.
Wo setzt man den Stands?
PAVK.
In den Wien setzt man keinen Stands.
Er hat eine KHK.
Dann liegt es sehr nahe, dass er auch eine Verkalkung in den Beinen hat.
Also eine periphere AVK.
Ich habe schon einmal gehört für TRVT ein Filter oder solche kleine Apparat,
manchmal eingesetzt oder ich bin nicht zuhause.
Aber nicht am Bein, das macht man an der Lunge, kann man das manchmal machen.
Bei der Lumenembolie kann man das wehnen.
Weiß ich jetzt nicht, aber...
Also das ist nicht unser Thema jetzt.
Genau.
Und er habe auch Niereninstituzenz laut dem Hausarzt.
Seine Nierenwerte waren nicht gut beim Hausarzt, als sie beim Hausarzt gewesen seien.
Als er beim Hausarzt gewesen seien.
Gewesen ist.
Okay.
Und als vegetative Anamneser war aufwählig für die Patient.
Er habe bemerkt, dass sein Urin ist dunkler als sonst.
Und seit 3-4 Tagen habe er Nachtschweiß und Inapätenz.
Ansonsten nehmen er Metoprolil 50 mg morgens und abends.
Thoracemit 10 mg morgens.
Xerraltor 20 mg morgens.
Und Insulin-Spritzze, Aktrapit und Landtus.
Viermal am Tag Spritz.
Und reagiere alläglich auf Penicillin und äußert sich Sanktem.
Mit einem ex-Sanktem.
Das war es, Herr Oberarzt.
Was ist Ihre Verdachtstärke, das hört sich nicht so.
Und wie hoch war der Blutdruck, bitte?
Ja, im Blutdruck ist 60-80.
60-80 oder 80 zu 60?
Ja, 80-60.
Okay.
Puls?
Puls ist 64, aber unregelmäßig.
Also, was hat er?
Eine Bradi-Arithmenie?
Eine Bradi-Kadie.
Und wie nächste Diabetiker haben Sie gesagt?
Was macht sein Zucker?
Zucker ist entgleist.
Er hat Zucker entgleisung 435.
Es kann ins Chroma gehen.
Haben Sie seine Blutgase gemessen?
Nein, ich habe keinen Blutgase-Wert.
Machen Sie das mal noch?
Haben Sie Laktat gemessen oder ist ein pH-Wert?
Das wäre wichtig.
Was wollte ich noch wissen?
Haben Sie sein Urin kontrolliert?
Ja, Urin ist auffällig.
Nitrit-Positiv.
Und Glucosid-Positiv.
Und Protein-Positiv und Zucker-Positiv.
Und Blutig aus.
Was ist jetzt Ihre Verdachtstiagnose oder Ihre Arbeitsdiagnose?
Ich glaube, das ist nicht eine Verdachtstiagnose.
Es kann zu viele Erkrankungen kommen.
Erhöre der Blutzucker ist auch wichtig.
Es kann Diabetes-Schiscoma sein.
Und eine Entzündung.
Weil sein CRP-Wert zu hoch 100,86.
Es kann Hanweck-Infektion sein auch.
Sein Hemoglobin-Wert ist wirklich schon niedrig.
7,5.
Und Glucosid 13.000.
Und Tromboziten 120.
Er hat Trombozitopeni.
Es kann Sepsis sein.
Sie gehen von einer Sepsis aus?
Ja, Sepsis.
Woher kommt Sepsis bei Ihnen?
Infektion-Werte.
CRP ist hoch.
Was ist die Rhose?
Woher die Sepsis kommt?
Von Hanweck-Infektion kann sein.
Wie nennt sich das?
Das ist eine Sepsis.
Was von Hanweck-Infektion kommt?
Die Sepsis.
Sie sagen, er hat eine Urosepsis.
Und in diesem Rahmen eine Diabetische Entgleisung.
Fast ein Diabetisches Coma.
Er hat ein niedriges Hemoglobin.
Ein Anämie.
Wahrscheinlich ein Atrial-Fibrile-Aktion.
Warum hat er das Xarelto?
Ich konnte nicht verstehen.
Warum hat er Xarelto?
Wahrscheinlich hat er eine Atrial-Fibrile-Aktion.
Er hat einen Entwakt.
Es ist anzunehmen, dass er schon Vorhoff-Limmern hat.
Aber er hat multiple internistische Vorerkrankungen.
In der inneren Medizin sagt man, es ist ein internistisches Politrauma.
Das habe ich neu gelernt.
Auch durch das sagen wir anders.
Sehr gut.
Unsere Diagnose ist Urosepsis.
Mit Diabetischen Coma.
Was machen Sie mit den Patienten?
Statunäraufnehmen.
Auf die Intensivstation.
Ich werde Zugang legen.
Und die Parameter bewerten.
Und die Bilanz der Utilien.
Und eine Antibiosin.
Und die Antibiosin.
Die Antibiosin.
Sehr gut, Herr Doktor.
Das haben Sie gut gemacht.
Und jetzt schnell auf die Intensivstation.
Danke.
Haben die Kollegen und Kolleginnen noch Fragen?
Ich habe immer wieder einige Notizen gesehen.
Urosepsis, Hyperkalimie.
Genau.
Ketone usw.
Selbstlicher Schock.
Keine Fragen.
Alle zufrieden.